i'm on a menstrual mission to eliminate
all plastic from period products
my name's ella i'm an environmental
activist and founder of the end period
plastic campaign i was working a regular
day
job as a postal worker for royal mail
while i was out delivering letters and
parcels i began to notice the amount of
waste being thrown away
each week was increasing you might be
thinking
why period products what's so bad about
them that the fifth
most common item found polluting
europe's beaches
they're more commonly found than straws
or coffee cups
tampons and pads are made in their
billions are used for four to eight
hours
are disposed of and can then take over
500 years
to break down my campaign calls on
manufacturers
and supermarkets to take responsibility
and bring about change by removing
plastic from their
period products the campaign is leading
to significant changes
in the period industry three uk
retailers removing plastic tampon
applicators
from their products saving over 17 tons
of plastic
each year